for this group of refugees the journeys
over at least for now they were picked
up and beaten they say by the Turkish
Coast Guard they were trying to make
their way to the Greek island of Lesbos
but these men women and children didn't
get far before they were intercepted and
returned to the Turkish port town of de
Kili they were beating us even after we
got off the ship they attacked us and
beat us take a look at him they've
beaten him - look at his face they hit
us all since the eu-turkey deal came
into effect
fewer refugees have attempted the
crossing from Turkey to Greece the
journey across the sea is now more
difficult and that's also making
business tougher for shop owners in yzma
who've made a tidy profit by supplying
refugees refugees would buy life jackets
and clothing from us before they fled
this allowed us to double our revenue
but since the turkey EU deal came into
effect we've been making 80 percent less
Muhammad Abdul Qadeer is one of the many
Syrians in Turkey who dreams of reaching
Europe but it's money that's stopping
him smugglers are now asking for more
money here in Turkey so it has become
much more difficult for Syrians to get
to Europe all migrants who attempt the
onward journey risk deportation they are
well aware of that but they say they
definitely do not want to stay in Turkey
whatever deal governments have agreed on
the refugees determination to make their
way to Europe is stronger than ever